>> So, it's my pleasure to
introduce Moshe Vardi
today from Rice University.
I've known Moshe since
before he was established
as a researcher,
actually his Ph.D. advisor was
my first major collaborator
as a researcher,
who at the time he was
at Hebrew University.
And he said, "John I got
this really great student.
And you want to
keep an eye on him,
this guy's really
going to be good."
I swear that
his accomplishments and
awards read like a list of
a large fraction of
the awards that are open
to any computer scientist.
It says three IBM outstanding
innovation awards,
the SIGACT Godel prize,
the ACM Kanellakis award,
the ACM SIGMOD innovations
award, Blaise Pascal medal,
National Academy of Engineering,
National Academy of Science,
American Academy of Arts
and Letters, and so on.
He also has done
a huge service to
the computer science community
by taking CACM,
which was a really
much ignored journal.
>> This is being recorded.
>> And really recasted,
resurrected it,
really conceptualized it, as in
a way and a vision
for how it could
actually be relevant
and widely read.
And he actually
made it happen and
served in addition to
everything else he does
being a famous researcher in
several different fields and
writing hundreds of papers.
Somehow he managed
to carve out time for
10 years to lead that effort
as editor-in-chief.
So, I think we all grow old
and regretted that a debt of
gratitude for having
done that as well.
Today, he's on a new mission
on the effect that we have
in automating all kinds of
work and what is that effect.
First, if we want
to improve the lot of people
whose jobs are eliminated,
I think the first
thing to do is to
understand exactly
what's going on,
and he's going to be telling us
about that today. So, Moshe.
>> Thank you.
Thank you for the opportunity
today to address you
on this topic which is I think
of the highest importance.
And just to give you some idea
where I'm coming at it.
So, it's probably
fair to say for
about 30 years of my career,
that was my main focus.
Published papers,
get them cited,
get a good h number.
But about five, six years ago,
I started thinking and I'll
explain a bit later how
come into it thinking
about the societal consequence
of the technology that we are
working so hard to develop,
and find myself
about two years ago
in a press conference.
And the reporter from
The Guardian asked,
"Which jobs will
not be automated?"
And I said the
conventional wisdom is
the job that required
a lot of human interaction,
and emotional intelligence, that
these jobs will
not be automated.
And then on the spur
of the moment,
I said, but I'm not so sure.
"Would you bet
against sex robots?"
And of course this
was a soundbite,
and you see The Guardian
ran with this headline,
and a thousand newspaper
quoted me on this one.
So, much so that some of
my friends now call
me sex robot Moshe.
So, let's recap the AI story.
First of all, in a very briefly
just to remind ourselves.
You know you cannot exactly
trace exactly where it started.
You can find some people say it
start really in
the 19th century.
You can go back and find
people thinking about this.
But maybe it's not
the arbitrary point to
identify with Alan Turing,
who in 1950 wrote
very well cited paper.
So, we mostly think
about Alan Turing
and Turing machines,
but the paper that
he published in 1950,
Computing Machine
and Intelligence
published in a
philosophy journal Mind.
I believe it's
his most cited paper.
And again, the paper is
very famous for
the Imitation game,
the Turing test, but it's
actually mapping on
the weakest part of the paper.
The main part of the paper is
a philosophical paper on
the possibility of
machine intelligence.
And Turing goes through
a list of objection to
machine intelligence and he
decisively argues
against all of them,
and he concluded by saying "Yes,
machines will be
thought to be thinking."
He said, "By
the end of the century,
we will talk as if
machines are thinking."
Well, the century
has come and gone,
and I don't think still
I will say, "Well,
my laptop is thinking about
what's the next slide to show."
I don't think that's
how we talk about.
And indeed, overoptimism was
a common feature
in the AI field.
You go back, Simon
and Newell,1958,
10 years marks we
will solve chess.
AI will take us maybe
30 years, said Minsky, 1967.
So because of
this early optimism,
the old periods became
known as AI Winters
where the field have almost
fallen into disrepute.
When I was a Ph.D student,
AI was a suspicious field.
People who overpromise
and underdeliver,
you can always come up with
some names that are
associated with these era.
And to me the turning point
on a personal level, on 1997.
So, I left IBM.
I was already at
Rice University.
I had a very good
connection with IBM.
IBM invited me to
come and watch the game
between Kasparov and Deep Blue.
They pay my flight, they pay for
the hotel, I couldn't say no.
So, I go there and I
watched the first game.
In the first game,
Kasparov was white,
which is perceived
to have an advantage,
and Kasparov won the first game.
And I remember
that then thinking,
"Okay I believe that
one day computer will win,
but probably the time
has not come."
And we're still
fairly new in Houston,
we didn't have many friends,
I let my wife behind,
I said okay, I'm going
to cut the visit short
and I'm going to go back home,
and I miss the second game.
The second game,
Deep Blue was white.
Kasparov had to play
more aggressive game,
and he lay the trap
to Deep Blue,
and Deep Blue not only did
not fall into the trap,
but came out of it with
a sequence of moves
that were so brilliant.
If you see Kasparov's
reaction to that,
he walks off, he
conceded the game,
he walks off the game.
And for years, he claimed
that it was not
really Deep Blue.
There must have
been a secretive of
Grandmaster playing against him.
Just last year, he
published finally
a book to the 20th
anniversary of this.
So, he said finally yes,
it was the computer has
won, he conceded it.
But that was really
a turning point
because he promised that for
years there were sometime,
the future, suddenly it was
the first significant
accomplishment by AI.
And then in 2011,
IBM did it again.
This time with Watson,
and now it was in Jeopardy.
Chess is a computational game.
If you can just look deeply
enough into the game tree,
you can defeat humans.
But Jeopardy require whole
different type of intelligence.
You have to answer
clever questions
about airports in Chicago
that had something to
do with World War II.
And you have to think,
"Well, it's midway airport."
And maybe to require
some kind of knowledge
of culture and history,
and language skills.
So, that was the moment
that for me I said, "Wow.
It's not just about
some remote future,
this is actually happening."
Now, I think the next
significant accomplishment
I would put what
happened last year,
which is now the mantle
has moved to IBM to Google,
and AlphaGo beat
Lee Se-dol in Go.
Now Go, you can see here,
Go in some sense,
a simpler game.
You'll have a 19 by 19 board,
just black and white pieces.
There are many, many
more configurations.
So the game tree is known to
be much, much, much bigger.
And therefore, Go
has been considered
a challenge after chess.
People have tried many,
many years to do better in Go,
and deterministic self
clear was not going to work,
so AlphaGo use, first of all,
randomize tree stars technique.
But still that's is not enough,
so now they use
machine learning.
And would have
done first of all,
they digested
all published games,
and then AlphaGo stop
playing against itself and
built a big deep model
of how to make,
what are good configuration,
what are good moves.
This is philosophically
significance
because it means now that
the way AlphaGo played is
by having deep intuition.
Not having good rules
how to play,
but having good intuition.
And to understand
the significance of these,
we have to go back
more than 50 years,
and find the
philosophy of Polanyi.
Karl Polanyi who wrote in 1966,
and this become known
as Polanyi's Paradox.
How can we ever hope to
have AI when there are many,
many things that we can do,
but we cannot explain
how we do that?
If you think about how
you drive, you just drive.
You don't have a set of
rules that you follow.
And the thought was,
if you don't have
a set of rules that we follow,
it's all about
intuitive feeling,
how can we ever program this?
And the answer is,
then we know what
is the answer, right?
Machine Learning.
We're going to learn
them from data.
And it's interesting
that the Polliani put
driving as the kind
of a challenge for AI,
because it has been
a grand challenge for
AI now for actually
more than a decade.
Going back in 2005,
the DARPA Grand Challenge,
eventually won by Stanford Team.
This is Sebastian Thrun,
in more than 130 miles
in unrehearsed trail
in Death Valley.
And two years later, a CMU
now doing it an urban area.
And notice, this is
more than 10 years ago.
This is before we had
all the cheap sensor that we
have today and before we
had the deep learning,
already people were making
significant progress
in automated diving.
And of course, by
now, this picture is,
I think everybody
here recognizes
the so-called the Google Car
or more formally the Waymo car.
Right? And so, I think
this is an amazing thing,
it was going to
happen. I'll talk more.
I want to talk about it, because
I think this is going to be
the most significant
technical development that
I'm going to see in
my lifetime as I expect this
too for many of you, okay?
Unless you're very young,
and then maybe you'll
see other thing.
But for most of us,
I think this is it.
And let me put it in a context,
why I think this
is so significant?
It's going to launch another
transportation revolution.
What's the first one?
Invention of the wheel,
about 5,000 years BC.
What has he done to us?
Well, we'll not been able to
build the pyramids if we
didn't have wheels, right?
You can't carry this big
boulders on your back.
What's the next one after that?
The domestication of the horse.
Okay. Until then, if you want
to go somewhere you
had to walk there.
Now, you can ride
there, you don't
have to work on your own feet.
And, if you think about it,
you have the Mongol Empire,
which is the biggest
land empire ever,
all concurred on a horseback.
After the domestication
of the horse,
which happen more
than 5,000 years ago.
Nothing significant happens
in land transportation,
I'm ignoring sea,
water transportation,
until the Steam Locomotive.
The Steam Locomotive
you can say,
it's the beginning of
the Industrial Revolution
in some sense, in a big way,
and we cannot imagine
the United States is
a continental country
if we did not have
this trains going
east, no, east-west.
Before that, if you
want to go from New York
to San Francisco,
what was the fastest way of
getting from New York
to San Francisco?
A boat all around America, okay.
So, the train made
the modern United States.
And then in 1908,
the Ford Model T,
the car at this point
is about 50 years old,
all Started in Europe
in the 1850's, I think.
But this is the first mass
produced, mass consumed car.
And it gave us this,
and this, and this.
The car, the
Automobile, I claim,
is the most significant
industrial product
of the 20th century.
We would like to think,
it's the computer.
No, it's not the computer.
The computer will probably be
the most significant product
with 21st century.
But if you bring someone
from 50 years ago, 1967,
and they go to sleep,
refund, wrinkled,
and wake up today, how does
the world look different?
Well, everybody carries
some something with
them and a lot of
zombies are walking
around looking at things.
But other than that,
the fabric of life
does not look that
different between
1967 and today.
Some years ago, I went to Cuba,
and it was like going in
time machine 50 years back,
and it looks dated,
but not dramatically different.
The city in 50 years now,
in the future, will be
dramatically different.
Because the cities of today
were shaped by the Automobile.
There were architect
by the automobile.
Because the United States
it's such a big country,
the Automobile of
such significance,
it gave right to
a mighty industry.
I mean, who can
remember this chairman
of GM saying 50 years ago,
what's good for GM is
good for the country.
The United States would not
have become a superpower,
if you don't have
the industrial might.
It came from
the automobile industry.
World War II was won by
the American industry.
Think of how many movies,
the Automobile play a role,
a cultural symbol of
adulthood and freedom,
and all of this is
going to change.
And it will change for
one important reason,
in these the human cost of
Automobile is incalculable.
We just learn them to accept it.
More than a million people
every year are
killed by the
automobile cautions,
30,000 in United States alone.
We just learn to accept it.
In fact, even the world car
accident is a marketing term.
Because if you say accident,
it's an act of God.
You know, it's beyond us.
And the social cost of it,
if you actually go
down to think about it,
how many people
are killed in main?
In affect, mostly people
in the middle part of
their life from about
teenage to early middle age.
In fact, takes us,
only finally now,
passed a law, it's
now illegal to
text and drive in Texas.
Thank you. Thank you. Thank you.
Thank you. The leading cause
of death among
young people today?
DW? Driving while?
>> Texting?
>> Texting. Used to be I, right?
Now, it's about, it's texting.
So, I think, this by itself
justify pushing for
the automation of car.
Now, this is a book published
by Ralph Nader in the mid-60's,
blaming the automobile industry.
But the reason that we
have so many car crashes,
you want to know why?
Look to your left, look to
your right. It's all about us.
95 percent of crashes
are caused by humans.
I do sometimes
an interesting experiment.
I asked everybody to write
down whether they're above
average driver or
below average driver.
Then I asked all the people who
are above average
to raise their hand,
and it's usually about 80
percent of the audience.
So, probably today
in Silicon Valley,
this is kind of the hot, one of
the hottest technical trend.
You have some estimates over
250 companies working
this area from the mainstream,
a car manufacturers: GM,
Ford, and the like.
Some technology
company: Waymore,
Baidu, maybe Apple,
nobody knows.
The transportation
companies such as Uber,
and Lyft, and lots,
and lots of startups.
Technical issues,
there's no agreement.
Some people say five years.
To me that sounds
overly optimistic,
maybe 15 is more realistic.
The adoption will
be more difficult.
I'd think it will take 20,
25 years for adoption.
It will be gradual.
There are many,
many legal issues that
need to be resolved.
In many states, the law says,
"A moving vehicle requires
to have a human driver
in the car."
So the laws will have to change.
It will be a profound
business disruption.
Most car seats, idly
and doing nothing,
and I will have an opportunity
to actually have
a more rational and more
effective use of the fleet.
Huge major loss of business
including for example,
people are now worried,
where will we get organs
for transplantation?
If we don't have all these
people killed by car crashes.
Still, I think of it is
going to be a huge benefit to
society mostly if we just can
save every year million lives,
I cannot see anything
more important than death.
But then, let's look
at this picture.
This is all the state,
this in 2014, I don't
think it's centromatically.
It shows all the
50 states and he
chose the most common job
in every state.
In more than half the states
is a truck driver.
That doesn't mean
that the majority of
the people in the center
are truck driver.
This is an artifact of how
you aggregate the jobs,
but still it tell you
there are lots of drivers.
Turns out in the United States,
there are about four million
truck and taxi drivers.
If you bought in the category,
you look at people whose job
include driving as
a major component of the job,
think of like postal workers,
now we're talking about
15 million people.
And in fact, if you
can automate vehicles,
you can automate really
the whole supply chain.
And if you look for example,
at cargo, cargo ship.
Well, they're much easier
to automate than cars.
Because you don't
have to deal with kids
chasing balls on the street.
And in fact, apparently,
they're going
to launch this year,
they are planning to
launch a cargo ship.
If you look at port, today.
Port today, are
almost hundred percent
containerized and it means
they can be fully automated.
I'm sure you have
seen the videos
of the Amazon warehouses,
where you have the robots
that move, move the things.
What still robots have
a hard time doing is this.
Picking up an object
is still hard,
but they're working on it.
So, we can see a huge disruption
of the economy and
massive local jobs.
Now, you talk to economists
about it and it's, "Oh, yeah.
Technologies for job,
it's create new jobs",
there's a new [inaudible]
was being reached.
Nothing to worry about.
That's the standard line
that you'll hear from economist.
Here is a Ken Rogoff,
a Neoclassical Economists
at Harvard, I think.
And he said, "Oh, people
have been worried about
mass unemployment in
industrial revolution.
It never happen, it never will."
Now, notice that
even he says something
about a long period
of painful adjustment.
Excuse me. How long exactly?
It doesn't say. Let's move on.
Don't worry. Nothing
to worry about.
Other economists such as
Paul Krugman,
Nobel Prize winner,
and a columnist
for New York Times,
is a bit more pessimistic.
He said, "can innovation and
progress really hurt
large number of workers,
maybe even workers in general?"
It will say that it can.
Yes. Maybe workers will be hurt.
So there is this debate
among the Neoluddites,
who were saying, "This
time it is different."
And then neoclassical who said,
"This time it is not
different." So who's right?
So this is now a matter in fact,
you can read it even a popular
media almost every week.
There is a new article
about this topic.
And in particular,
the site new studies.
McKinsey has a study.
Gartner has a study.
Oxford University has a study.
OECD has a study.
Pricewater Cooper has a study.
Everybody has a study
and every study come
up with different prediction
for the future.
So why are we seeing
so many different prediction
for the future?
Well, there is a Danish
proverb and it says,
"Predictions are hard,
especially about the future."
But I think the Danish
got it wrong.
Predictions are easy,
especially about the future.
Everybody can make a prediction.
Go ahead, make a prediction.
Quite predictions.
This is the hard part, okay.
Now, notice all
these predictions are
usually for 30 years
in the future.
Who is going to
check in 30 years
if the government was correct,
or McKinsey was correct?
Nobody's going to check it.
And so, our answer is nobody
knows what's in the future.
The future is inherently
unknown, okay?
We can predict the weather about
24 hours into the future.
That's about maybe
a few days into the future.
Instead, I want to
spend now the rest of
the big part of the time
talking about the past.
And I'm going to
use a case study,
American manufacturing.
Why American manufacturing?
One, first of all,
the United States is
a good test case for
this because it's
a very large economy.
It's about 25 percent
of the world's GDP.
And it's a very
market-based economy
more than many of the economies
in Europe, for example.
Their government plays a role in
economy than in many,
many other countries.
And manufacturing is by
far the biggest sector
of the economy,
almost twice as big
of the next sector,
which is government.
And government here is
government at all level,
not just the federal government.
So manufacturing is huge.
Just to give you another example
of the size of manufacturing,
US manufacturing is about
the size of Germany,
and Korea, and
France, and Russia,
and Brazil, and UK combined.
China is slightly bigger
than United States.
So US manufacturing is huge.
This may come a little bit as
a surprise because
we've been hearing,
manufacturing's all gone, right.
Everything went to
China and Mexico.
But this is all propaganda.
Manufacturing is
huge. Now here is,
to me, this is a slide when
I saw it, it was a shocker.
So US manufacturing
when you look at
volume in constant dollars
in this curve,
you can see it's been
going up for 50 years,
more than 60 years.
Of course, it zigzags. There are
economic cycles but it goes up.
But employment peaked
at around 1980,
and it's been down
roughly since then.
With some a little recovery
from the recession here.
But we have lost
roughly one third of
manufacturing jobs
over the past 35 years.
Another way to look at it,
which is that manufacturing
as a fraction of the economy,
it's very, very stable.
It's around 12 percent and it's
been like that for
more than 50 years.
But we used to
have 25 percent of
the labor force in
manufacturing and now we
are at about 8 percent.
So why is it happening?
Well, it's very clear
why it is happening.
It is happening because
manufacturing productivity
has increased.
Over the past 20 years,
it has roughly doubled.
In effect, it's surprising.
We only lost one third
of the labor force in
manufacturing other than half
of the labor force
in manufacturing.
>> Don't you ignore
the China effect?
>> So, the point
is if volume is up,
now what is the role
of China here?
So because of
the globalized world,
the manufacturing worldwide
is more competitive.
And what it meant that US had to
shift from low
margin industries.
So we don't make sneaker
anymore in the United States.
This shirt was probably not
made in the United States.
We moved the manufacturing
to high margin,
high capital
intensive industries.
So when I said that
interest is going up,
it does not mean
that all is that -
there's no huge change
underneath.
And automation globalization
are tied together.
And automation of
globalization is done,
it increase
the competitive level,
and that enables automation
to become more profitable.
Automation would
have happened anyway,
because even in this country,
it's very competitive.
So even if we don't have
to compete with China,
one company will automate,
it force the other
company to automate.
And if you want
to see automation,
just Google, excuse
me, search, search.
Tesla Model S factory Floor,
and you can get very nice videos
of the Tesla factory floor,
where they will tell you
the only reason the lights
are on so they can
take the picture.
Otherwise it could be
a dark factory floor.
And it reminds me of what
used to be an old joke in
GM when they started
putting industrial robots.
The joke was that the factory of
the future will have all robots,
one man, and one dog.
And the purpose of the dog is
to make sure that the man
does not touch the machines.
And the role of the men
is to feed the dog.
So now, we can ask,
"Okay, all these happen.
All these millions
of people lost
their job, what happened?"
This is a good task as
what happened, right?
So the neoliberal economy
will tell you,
"Oh well, they should
find other jobs.
There should be a
new equilibrium."
So now, let's go and examine
what really happened.
And in a nutshell what I want to
show you is the last
40 years have been
actually very harsh on
working class and middle class
low middle class, the Americans.
And this is something
that I have to say.
The data that I shared
came as a surprise to me.
And I've been reflecting
on it why is that?
And I've concluded that
we hear a lot about
the one percent but
the real divide
in society is not
the one percent, the 99 percent.
It's the 20 percent
versus the 80 percent.
And we're in 20 percent,
all of you are part
of the 20 percent
because you are
educated professionals.
And that's roughly people with
undergraduate, some
post-graduate education.
That's about 20 percent
of the population.
And for these people, if you
think about how you
spend your life,
I would bet that
the vast majority of
your friends belong
to the top 20 percent,
and if you have a spouse,
most likely your spouse
come from the same group.
So this group creates
its own bubble.
We all live inside this bubble,
and everything is filtered
through that bubble and
we see very little what's
happening outside that bubble.
We have little idea
what's happening
in decaying towns in
the South or in the Midwest.
And the bottom line
is that I want to show
how the automation poses a very,
very serious challenge
to developed economies.
We can discuss
developing economies,
if you want at the very end.
And I think as a society,
we must develop policy to
address this challenge.
So let's see what happened to
the economy of
the last 40 years.
So this is data that
was put together by
Erik Brynjolfsson and
Andrew McAfee at MIT,
and they have looked
at four numbers that
are very important here.
One is productivity, because
the economy grows is it
because there are more people
or people become
more productive?
And so productivity growth is
the engine of economic growth.
And indeed you see here
that from the early 50's,
for the next 30 years,
productivity grows and with
productivity, GDP grows,
the economy grows, jobs are
generated, and income grows.
So this becomes
the Goldilock period.
And you look at all these
numbers, and you think, "Okay.
They're so nicely well aligned,
you'd think there must
be some economic law that
productivity growth drive
everything? Everything goes up.
Except at what happened starting
from roughly to mid 1980,
we see a divergence.
We see a decoupling.
And these cellular,
the productivity
continued to grows
and the GDP grows,
but we're not
creating enough jobs,
and income has stagnated.
And here's an example
of income stagnation.
This is, I think,
a nice way to look
at income stagnation.
This is real median
yearly income
of white men with
no college degree.
And you can see that it's
actually has gone down
between 1975 and 2015
has gone down.
And this is, I have to
say, that few slides
to me when I saw them, I gusp,
because to realize that
here in the United States,
for a very large sector
of the economy,
thing have gone be now gone
for all now for 40, 50 years.
It's shocking.
And think about what we saw
in political rally in 2016.
We saw angry white men.
Now we used to see these men,
usually there will be
somewhere in the middle east,
and they usually will
say something like
death to America,
death to America.
And now, we are finding
these people right
here in our midst.
And you ask, "Okay, what
are they so angry about?"
Well, this is what
they're angry about.
Okay? They see the life quality
declining for
a whole generation.
And we also have been hearing
a lot about growing inequality.
So this shows you that
if you look again,
this is between 1980 and 2013.
And you see the bottom
90 percent decline.
This is the top one percent.
And then you see the people
who really did well are
the top one percent of
the top one percent.
They did really, really
well in this economy.
And in particular what
it means is that part of
the American dream was
of life getting better,
except what you see here,
is that the top one percent
used to own about 12 percent.
We used to get about 12
percent of the income.
It's going up to 20 percent.
The bottom 50 percent
used to get
about 20 percent of
the income. It has gone down.
It's like some people
call it a tale of
two countries where
one country is doing
better and better,
and one country is
doing worse and worse.
And on top of it,
we used to think that
this is a country
that enable a lot
of social mobility.
That is to say that
every generation,
the next generation
will do better
than the current generation.
And what you see
here is that in 1940,
if you're 30 years old,
the poverty was 90 percent.
If you're doing better than
your parents when they
were 30 years old.
Now it's 50-50.
It's a contours where
they're going to do better
or worse than your parents
when they were at similar age.
Okay. This is another
very significant thing.
You'll hear a lot
about how unemployment
now is very very low.
Unemployment that is report in
the news is a charade.
It's called U3.
It's a concept invented by
politicians to give us
good news because
what does it measure?
How many people that are looking
for jobs are not finding a job?
Does not measure
how many people stop
looking for a job
because they gave up.
And, this was to
me the second gasp.
Labor vote
participate, these are
people who are either
working or looking for a job.
This are what's
called labor force.
This is for men
between 25 and 54.
The reason it's
important to isolate
men for two reasons, why?
The picture for women you can
imagine is more complicated,
they first enter the workforce
starting from the 60s,
now it's also in decline but,
it's a more nuanced picture.
Also we're talk about
manufacturing, it's mostly men.
Here you'll see there's been
going down now for 50 years,
and it's even starker when you
look what happened and you
include education level.
You see the people
whose Bachelor Degree
has gone down a little bit,
but people with
high school degree or
less is gone down even
more significantly.
That means that, if you
look now at men with
High School education or less
probably about something like
one in four is not working.
This is to me when
heard of it, I
said, this is unbelievable.
This is what we
think of a country in
the midst of a depression,
when you hear about Greece,
this unemployment level of
25 percent not working
outside of the labor force.
I cannot think of
anything to say,
this is to me a National crisis
except that we
don't hear about it.
If you dig in Labor economy
will say, ''Oh Yeah,
we know about this,'' but
this is not on the News.
The 25 percent of working
class men are not working.
Working class men
are not working.
Somehow, I've develop of
hiding and nothing
seem to work out,
I apologize for that.
And the final thing
that I want to show
here on the label is for many,
many years you saw that labor
and capital are roughly
50-50 percent of the economy,
and except again,
this was the case for
many years and people thought
again it's an Economic Law.
That economy have offered to be
split between capital and labor,
but we're seeing again
labor now declining
for about 40 years
labor with declining.
So, what's going on? I think
the following plot kind of
explain what's going on.
This was put by
David Autor who was
a Labor Economist at MIT.
And what he said, let's look and
here it's a combination
of many plots.
It's of smooth curve.
It look at so-called
the Skill Spectrum.
So, high-skilled jobs pay well,
and low-skilled jobs
do not pay well.
If you look at the skill level,
are jobs being
generated or declining?
And what you see is in
the upper part of the skill
spectrum, we generate jobs.
Okay? We know that here
in a Computer Science,
the demand exceeds the supply.
For example, this is
a high-skilled job.
The very end of
the skill spectrum,
we're also generating jobs.
Why is that? Think of
the job of cleaning table
of the busboy,
cleaning table at
the restaurant.
So, first of all, you want
a grand challenge in robotic?
Do it, build a robot that
can clean tables
in the restaurant.
Okay, we don't have
the technology to do it.
The level of dexterity,
agility and situation
awareness that such a robot
will have to exhibit is
way beyond what we can do.
But we can take someone
who has even not
a High School Degree,
and pay the minimum wage
and they are going
to do the job.
So, there is
no reason to automate
jobs at that part
of the spectrum.
So, where do we automate jobs?
In the middle of
the skill spectrum.
Why are we automating jobs here?
Take manufacturing, we pay
manufacturing employee
$20 to $30 an hour.
Well, it's a
significant investment.
Okay? This is three times
four times more
than minimum wage.
What's the skill level?
It's medium.
It's a fairly routine job.
You keep doing the same
thing over and over.
These are the things that
we know how to automate.
So, here this is
the sweet spot for automation.
What David Autor had shown,
Autor also has show what happens
over time and what you see is,
this sweet spots get
broader because as the
capability of robots increase,
more and more jobs can
be defined as routine.
It also moves to
the right, moves upwards.
Okay? So, this is like
the ozone hole, it
gets bigger and bigger.
And, one way you
can look at it is by
a looking at the income
according to Degree.
And you can see that people
who have advanced Degrees,
this is between 73 and now
the income has risen.
This is true for also College,
if you have just some College,
if you didn't finish four year,
you have some College,
you barely kept up,
but if you have
High School or less you
actually again you
have lost ground.
These are the jobs
that there are lots of
people who can do this job
so, they're not
paid well at all.
>> You hit play, you'll
skip all the hit points.
If you hit play, you'll
>> Maybe this is the problem
here, let me try,
let me see what happened here.
>> It's right next
to 77 percent.
>> Play, Where is play?
>> Right next to the 77 percent
down the bottom corner,
turn right, there you go.
>> There we go, I didn't
do that. Okay, well
okay. Sorry, I
forgot to do that.
Here is the final gasp slide,
this is data uncovered
by economists,
two economists at Princeton.
They look at mortality, and
with all the Boehner
on Healthcare,
mortality keeps going down
because Healthcare
keeps improving.
But, they found
that this does not
hold for White people
in United States.
It holds for Hispanics,
hold for Blacks.
You can look abroad, it
happens in every country.
Healthcare gets
better and better,
but they found that White
in the United States,
our mortality is going up.
This is between 45 and 50 folks.
These are middle-aged people,
and again if you look
at it by Education,
you find that this is related
to lack of College Education.
And if you dig
deeper and say okay,
what are these people
dying from?
You find the leading causes are
suicide and drug overdose,
we all hear now about
the opioid epidemics and
liver diseases and all
of these what they call
are disease of the despair.
So, these people are
suffering from despair,
and we can ask again
what's going on?
I mean we're talking
about right now,
for example I believe that
opioid epidemics kill
more people than guns.
Can you imagine what can kill
more people than gun
in United States.
And so, to top it this
is from March of 2016.
This is before even Trump
clinched the
Republican Nomination.
The Washington Post,
look at the correlation
between mortality
and voting for Trump,
and they found out that
the areas where there
was higher mortality,
more despair, people
were voting for Trump.
So, this economic development
have serious political
consequences.
This is what the economists
again put Counties by
different index
of health metrics
and you can see if you get
healthier it's becoming bluer,
and as you get less
healthy it becomes red.
Okay, so there is
a clear correlation here
between Economics, Health
and Political inclinations.
And to me this reminds
of very classic quote.
I want to see if
anybody recognizes it.
"All that is solid
melts into air,
all that is holy is profaned,
and man is at last compelled
to face with sober senses,
his real conditions of life,
and his relations
with his kind."
Anybody recognizes it? Do we?
I thought that you'll
have the proper,
if anybody you should
had the proper education.
>> [inaudible] it was
a good place to ignore all this.
>> So there is
a sense of dislocation
that reminds people,
the feeling that
happened in the middle of
the 19th century where and I'll
come back in a few minutes
to the Industrial Revolution.
Now, you look at all this data.
And first of all, almost
any economic data,
people question
because everything,
for example, you look
at I said real income.
Well real income, you
have to factor inflation.
How do you measure inflation?
There are different way
to measure inflation.
Every piece of data here is
a somewhat controversial,
but I think the general picture
gives something that even
if you need pick it
every single plot here,
you still see
Excel picture emerging.
But as everybody tells you,
correlation does
not imply causation.
What is the cause of this?
And economically, it's very
hard to determine causation.
Okay? It's very, very
difficult to do it.
So in 2014, an opinion poll
was conducted.
The Pew Charitable
Foundation conducted
a opinion poll amount
about 2,000 economists.
And again, it's a poll so
it does not tell you truth.
We have to take it
with a grain of salt.
But there was a
significant really.
It was a plurality for accepting
the automation is
a central reason.
Again, it's not the only reason
life is more complicated.
It's a central reason
for wage stagnation.
Now, I think
the picture has changed
and partly because there
is a new study that just
came up last year from
economists at MIT,
and they went city
by city and look at
deployments of an industrial
robots versus job losses.
And again, remember,
this all correlation,
but I think the weight of
evidence is coming
more and more that
automation plays a major role
in the dislocation of
the working class people.
Now, let's talk
about this argument.
This time it is
different or not.
So again, the argument
we hear a lot,
technology destroying job
but it create new jobs.
Jobs that we cannot even
fathom will be created.
But let's do
a thought experiment.
If you are working
AI, what is your goal?
Your goal is to look
one by one at
human capabilities and try
to test this dream of
artificial intelligence
to be able to build machine
that will be just
as smart as people.
Let's suppose that we succeed.
I don't know if this will
take 20 years or 100 years.
Let's suppose that we succeed.
Somehow, because
this assumption means that there
will always be something
that people are better at.
And I don't see how you can
argue that people will always
be better than machine.
In fact, unless you go
into some metaphysics,
we are some kind of
a biological machine.
Evolution had millions of years
to perfect task.
It may take some time for us
to compete with evolution,
but I can't see
anybody who come up
with an argument whereby
all you people will always
be better than
machine in some way.
I just don't see
that. And in fact,
if economists should
know about anything,
it's about the concepts
as a tipping point.
Okay. What is the tipping point?
To face transition.
There was popular book
by Malcolm Gladwell,
in 2005, demonstrated many,
many cases where
a quantitative change
finally lead to
a huge qualitative change.
And in fact, what is
the biggest qualitative
change that we
have experienced in
human history? There are a few.
You will say
Agricultural Revolution,
then the Industrial Revolution.
So imagine you are an economist
in the year 1700 and
somebody asked you to predict
economic growth for
the rest of the millennium.
We'll say, "Well, I have
economic data going back since
Moses brought the two tablets,
and these data show me that
economic growth is always
maybe 0.1% per year."
So we get confidence,
"I'm going to predict for
the next 300 years
economic growth
will be 0.1% per year."
Well, you would be wrong
because the Industrial
Revolution happened.
And so are we now on
the cusp of another kind
of people talk about the
fourth Industrial Revolution?
I don't know, but I don't know
how we can exclude
that possibility.
And in fact, this possibility,
there was a very
parabola attributed
appeared in a paper
by Wassily Leontief
who was a Nobel Prize
winning economist.
And he wrote about as
a parabola of two horses having
a conversation in maybe 1910.
In one horse is
a new Luddite horse.
And he tell the other one,
other horse, a neoclassical,
"Have you heard
about the Ford Model
T. I'm incredibly worried.
I think this new technology
will destroy jobs for horses.
What will we do after
deployment of the automobile?"
And the neoclassical horse says.
"Come on. Technology
always destroy
job for horses and it
create jobs for horses."
There'll always be
new jobs for horses,
job that we cannot yet
fathom and predict.
Well, we know which horse was
right because horse population
peaked in 1915,
and today, there are no jobs
for horses. Horses are pets.
Okay. This is the reality
if you're a horse.
We can argue that maybe it's
a better deal for
them. I don't know.
That's a horse equine
philosophy debate.
But in terms of jobs,
there are no more jobs
for horses.
And then people say, "Come on.
The Industrial
Revolution happening.
Look. Everything worked out.
We're okay." And
my answer is, "Really?
Have you learned your history?
Of course, we are okay now.
We're 200 years later
but first of all,
to fully adapt to
Industrial Revolution,
we had to invent a new thing,
a new institution.
It's called the
social welfare state.
It took 200 years.
The maturity of
the social welfare state
happens after World War II
in the '50s and in the '60s.
Many, many things in
this country only happened in
Great Society legislation of
Lyndon Johnson in the '60s.
So it took us
200 years to adapt.
Okay. It was not
an easy adaptation.
There were two communist
revolution with
about 100 million people
who died in them.
Even in this country,
we forgot there
were riots with
dozens of people,
not black people, white people,
being shot by police.
We forgot how difficult
was to adapt to
Industrial Revolution.
And now, we have
learned nothing from it?
We're going to repeat,
we are going to wait for
another 200 years of pain and
agony before we
learn to adapt to
the next phase of technology?
Of course, technology
creates up and destroy jobs.
I mean this is obvious,
but this is too simplistic.
Will technology
create enough jobs?
How fast will it create them?
What about the skill level?
So take a taxi driver
who lost his job
because now the taxi
have been automated and
it's only going to be the
first thing will be automated,
will be long-distance
tracking will
be the first thing to probably
to be automated before,
we do it inside in
the center of cities.
And you tell this truck driver
who are very slowly
lost their job,
"But we have openings,
people who write software for
autonomous trucks.
Please apply."
Also, where are the jobs
being now destroyed
in small cities,
in the south, and in
mid west while
they're being created?
Lots of jobs in Seattle.
Okay. Sell a job,
sell a house in Kalamazoo,
Michigan, and move to Seattle.
Easier said than done.
People cannot move.
Location, location,
location was said
about real estate.
And this just came up
on about a month ago,
LinkedIn top emerging jobs.
Look at this list of jobs.
Very exciting list of jobs.
I don't even know what it is.
What is it?
The virtual reality,
okay. Thank you.
Okay. How many of
these jobs goes to
people with high school degree?
So we have an economy
that creates
fantastic jobs at the high end
of the skill ladder.
>> It's really a bias
at recently [inaudible].
>> Well, you look
at the other cases.
But I will tell you.
Let's come back to
other type of jobs.
Okay so. This is very recently.
Oren Etzioni, down
the street from here at
an article in Wired magazine,
"Workers displaced
by Automation Should
Try a New Job: Caregiver."
Well, okay.
How much do we pay caregiver?
Again, at the high end,
if you're a physician
assistant, you'll be paid well.
But it require
several years of training.
If you're going to go for
a low-level caregiver,
pays very little because
the skill level is low.
The lots of people who can
do the job does not pay well.
Generally, people move from
manufacturing to services
lose 50% of their wages.
This is a big, big loss.
Any of you, consider losing
50% of your income.
It's a big loss.
But even beyond the money,
take this big guy who used
to work on manufacturing,
and we said, "We need to
go and wash old people."
And many, you can say,
"Well, it's a noble job.
My parent is dancer.
These people will tell you
very often, "That's
not who I am."
And even if they were
willing to do that,
if this big guy would show up
in a nursing home and came here,
he probably not get the job.
They'll probably hire
a woman to do the job.
So that cultural biases on
all sides and we
consider irrational,
we can complain about them,
but people are not widgets.
People are people. They
come with older biases.
We cannot ignore it. And we
talk about quantity of jobs.
So here is to me,
this is very start.
Go back to Detroit just in 1990.
And you find an industry
with a market value of
about $65 billion in
real dollars and more
than 1 million workers.
Now go to Silicon
Valley of 2016.
You find an industry, the
big three last company,
which is a Google and
Apple and Facebook,
and the market value then
was about $1.5 trillion,
less than 200,000 employees.
So, something about the number
of the new jobs very
generic but the
numbers don't match
the old job that we're losing.
And it's amazing that we went
through election
campaign in 2016,
and we heard a lot about trade,
we heard nothing
about automation.
Not from Clinton,
and not from Trump.
I'm not surprised
about Trump, but
I'm a bit surprised
about Clinton.
The only politician who
did talk about automation
was President Obama who was
not running for anything,
and he did observe that we are
seeing jobs moving from
manufacturing to services,
if we're moving and then,
people are losing
half their income.
And he said something
which I think is very
important which is kind
of get to the bottom line.
Everything we know about work
in our life is
a fairly modern thing.
It's not just
industrial evolution,
industrial evolution plus
the social welfare state.
Okay. And some people
call it the
social compact that
we are living by.
And it took 200 years to make
it happen. Right to strike.
Remember, we saw the picture of
people striking in Pittsburgh,
and we saw the train
station burning,
and more than 60
people shot by police.
The right to unionize.
Abolish child labor.
Working hour workweek.
Equal pay for
women and minority.
Health and safety laws. It took
a long time for this to happen.
And big fights over
everything because always
there was resistance to
every new improvement in
social and labor legislation.
There's a new kid on
the block called
universal basic income,
and universal basic income,
the idea is that we're
going to do away with
a lot of welfare program
repressed by universal,
every citizen gets a monthly
check from the government.
It's radical idea, even
though it goes back,
you can find Thomas Paine
writing about it.
He said, because the land
belonged to everyone originally,
there should be,
everybody should get some
kind of a lead dividend.
You find, interesting
you'll find support
for these ideas from the left
but also from the right.
People like Milton Friedman
who was in favor,
Charles Murray was in favor,
and why do people,
you can see why the socialist
would support it.
Why would people on
the right support it?
For two main reasons.
One is the hate the nanny state,
the hate the bureaucrats
making decisions about
who should get money
is a really simple to
get everybody money
and kill huge parts
of the bureaucracy.
And secondly, it will actually
create a more
efficient labor force.
And the reason is that
a labor market will become
more efficient
because right now,
there are many people,
their job sucks.
They're not paid
well. They cannot
afford to look for another job.
They have to be there.
They just don't have
the flexibility to
look for another job.
If the heaven is a safety
network, they would say,
I hate this job, I'm going
to look for another job.
So, these are the arguments
there are people
on the left and on the right
that hate this idea.
One of the reason that I'm
going to be skeptical
about this idea
personally is because it
ignores the psychological
value of work.
It only deal with
the socioeconomic value of work.
It ignores the
psychological value
of work where there
is a lot of research.
At least, in today's culture,
it plays such a huge role in
our own personal self-value.
And I want to finish with
a quote quoting Jason Furman,
who was the outgoing chair
of Council of Economic Affairs
President Obama,
and he says, "My worry is
not that this time could
be different when
it comes to AI,
but at this time, could be
the same as what we have."
That is if you look
at the past 50 years,
and you just project
forward the same trend,
you don't have to
change anything,
you don't have to say,
I'll be in another
phase transition.
Just taken all these trend
we have seen,
and just extend them
for the next 50 years,
and we're in fairly bad shape.
So, I think we're facing, to me,
that if you ask me that kind of
too huge policy challenges
and domestic policy challenges,
one is climate change,
and the other one is what I
would call shared prosperity.
I mean, there's no question
that technology will
create tremendous
amount of wealth.
How do we do in such a way
that the country as
a whole benefits from it?
Thank you very much. Ben.
>> Sir, I'm going
back to the horses.
The population of the earth
might decrease over time, right?
And so, one possible solution to
this conundrum is that the
human population just shrinks.
Do you think that's
a reasonable possibility?
And if so, could it happen
fast enough that it would
actually avoid some of
the challenges
you're talking about?
>> So, let me
broaden your issue,
and it said that
this talk ignore one huge,
another huge trend
and demographics.
And demographics is currently
one thing we see is
aging of the population,
and so what the book says, Oh,
we need all the robots
we can have
to take care of
the older people.
Okay. This is one,
and the other one
is that as societies
get richer generally,
the reproductive rate declines.
So, demographer kind
of thing that
we will peak at
about 10 billion,
then we'll start declining.
I have to say getting to 10
billion they're talking
about somehow the
next like 2100 that will
mean just too far to
really think what happened.
I mean, I'm just worried about
how do we navigate the next 25,
30 years of 2100,
is it just a bit too far for me?
How aging interact with it?
This is a huge question,
and I have to say,
I have not seen a really,
really good answers about it.
So, it's a very good questions,
what's going to be?
How does technology and
automation interact with
aging of their workforce?
I have not seen very,
very good answers to that.
I think nobody knows, yeah,
but it's a good question.
Yes? Speak up so I can hear you.
>> Yes, so there's
sort of an observation,
so you sort of handled 2020
of the idea of
universal basic income.
But the thing that you
objected to about it
was that there is the
psychological value of doing work.
So, I wonder how well
studied isn't like.
Suppose we doubled minimum wage.
Unemployment is very
little right now.
Undoubtedly, it would rise some,
but for other people
who have remaining work,
they would be getting
substantially more than it
might be a way of forcing
the people that are
making a lot more money
right now to value
the services that those people
are providing more highly,
and maybe a way of
spreading things out.
That might be
another way other than
universal basic
income that still
preserves that
the standard that you like.
>> There are a lot of speculation,
what happened, I mean,
look part of the issue
is, what happened when
right now economy is based
on people working and consuming.
What happen if more and
more people aren't working?
What will be the engine
of economic growth?
And people who says, well,
in a world where
most of the things are
produced by robots,
it will be suddenly
a new human economy.
Just like that people are
now willing now to pay
more for handmade things.
Somehow, there would
be a flowers of
all human economy
that were created.
My answer is, nobody knows.
This is the future.
Nobody could have
predicted 100 years ago
how society will evolve.
I think we have
a polymer hence now,
and I don't know that
we can come up with
the ultimate answer but I
think on the other hand,
ignoring, I mean, telling
people, don't worry.
If you tell people,
some people will say,
look, it's hard for you but
your children will do okay.
Maybe people can take it.
But if you tell people,
going to be hard for you,
going to be hard
for your children,
maybe your grandchildren
will be okay.
For most people, it's
not an acceptable answer.
Right? They would like to see.
So, we need to come up do
something without
worrying so much,
what happened in
the very long term?
And my answer is,
nobody knows what will
happen in a very long-term.
There was a question
there in the back?
>> You just answered, thank you.
>> So, I have a question
regarding the importance of
the economy in the first place.
Some anthropologists argue
that civilization is not
a natural state for human
that actually
hunters and gathers,
that's what we want to be.
So, couldn't we have
a different society,
very commonly that
does play such an
important role where there isn't
that psychological need to be
acknowledged where we work.
It's a completely
different system
especially when we have
a donation for support.
>> So, Jared Diamond,
he's famous for what is Guns,
Germs and Steel, but he
also, or if you Google,
you'll find article he wrote,
humanity's greatest mistake.
And his argument,
humanity's greatest mistake
was starting the
agricultural revolution.
He said, we're better
off as hunters gatherers.
And in a sense, you can find
the biblical parable of
the expulsion from
the garden of Eden,
was in some sense referred
described what happened, right?
So, they had to go and by
the sweat of thy brow
thou shall eat bread.
So, you could be right but
for the last 10,000 years,
we've been living as farmers,
and then as industry.
And one thing we know,
we maybe able to handle slow
changes and we have adopted,
human have adopted in
a incredibly resilient way,
but we don't deal
well with fast change.
So, if you have,
suddenly you say,
we are going to go from
between now and the 25 years
to a culture of kind
of enforced leisure.
So, some people tell
me, leisure is great.
I will finally be able to write
all the poetry that
I want to write.
And I always dreamed of taking
a water color painting and
I want to then point to do that.
We actually have data. What do
people do when
they're not working?
And the answer really
depends on their age.
Older people watch television,
younger people play video games.
So, somehow, you tell
to me the future of
humanity is TV and video games.
I find it a dystopia.
I don't know about you. Yes.
>> So, most of the charter
you showed was from the US?
>> Yes.
>> These trends around
technology or global.
Can you cite countries
that might be doing
a better job on
the policy front with
central parts of economy?
>> So, there is
a whole other talk
somebody could give on
the international aspect of it.
One thing that comes very
clear when you look at
international data
is policy matters.
How country would respond to
that definitely
makes a difference.
For example, Germany is
right now still has 25 percent
of the people in manufacturing.
But it used to be 40 percent.
So, it's going down but
going down more slowly.
One way they do that
the working class
people there had
better education than
in the United States.
So, this is something
you're going to see
how different countries
are responding to that.
That's one issue that
we're going to face.
>> Something from your talk
that fascinated me was,
there's this gasp moment
which I first would like this,
we're developed
in this technology
that is going to generate
this very painful potentially
next couple of centuries,
and let's keep working on it.
We'll figure it out.
And I'm trying to think
what actionable things we can do
as responsible scientists to,
I don't know, the limit?
We're building an atomic bomb.
What's the worst that can
happen? Let's give them-
So, really trying to
identify potential courses of
actions for us to help out.
We're not economists,
at least I know I'm not.
So, from the AI point of
view or machine learning,
does it make sense we are more
thoughtful about
what we want to do?
>> So, you know that they,
probably the question
is what should we
do and who has
the knowledge to do it.
And the answer is, right now,
I don't think the knowledge
is coming for us, okay?
We're pretty much I look
around me, we're techies.
And what we need to,
in fact, we tend to typically,
we end up being a bit somewhat
dismissive of Social Science,
but some of this answer will
come from Social Science.
They need to work with us.
Partly because they need
to have an understanding
where technology is going,
what are the trends,
but the answer is,
whether we should have
universal income or not,
I don't think this is something
that the people from
Computer Science
would come up with the answer.
[inaudible] who is
now very concerned
about social impact
of technology
said the answer is
not less technology,
more social wisdom into which
the way he described it.
I've been to, everybody
is looking for some,
we are again, we are
techie, were like
one magic bullet we
will solve the problem.
Answer is, we're not finding it,
we'll find a place of things.
We can look at, for
example, think tax policy.
So, we just said the tax reform.
Tax reform and give incentive
for capital investment.
Is that what we
really need right now?
Maybe we need investment for
companies to invest
more in the workforce.
So, right now, we just
passed a new recession
about taxes and this
encourages capital investment,
and because you can
expense it immediately,
and less investment
in the workforce.
So, even tax legislation
is relevant to this debate.
What about the education?
So, right now, we are,
the education scheme was
designed, did you
finish high school?
You are ready for the job.
You are ready for a job.
That doesn't work anymore.
We have to rethink
our education system.
So, that we maybe moving pieces,
and I have to say,
I'm struggling myself.
What's our position on this?
What do we do in this thing?
And first of all,
I would say is,
first of all, we need to
assume responsibility.
We are this technology,
it's us, we've created it.
It's not clear that immediately
we'll say that we
need to do something,
but first of all we should say
we are part of the conversation,
we cannot ignore it. Yes?
>> I'd like to see a chart
that looked at across
our other countries.
The proportion of
the population out
of work and the likelihood
that that country will
have some kind of
significant revolution that
would destroy the society.
That's a danger.
We might not be able to
fix the problem before
something bad happens.
>> So, Andrew McAfee for MIT,
his quote is, "The people will
rise before the
machine will rise."
And so, historically,
when you look at
continents where the gap,
the inequality goes more
and more and more, yeah,
these are the things
that leads to
very significant
political outcomes.
I think you look
at what's happening
in the United States now,
and it says, well, I
don't know if you
call it a revolution,
but it's a very
significant outcome of what
happened in 2016. Ben.
>> It's a related question
about what technology,
how we should take technology.
Is there a place for
the government to slow down,
say the adoption of
automated self-driving cars.
For example, because it would
give society
more time to adjust.
In some level, even
if we can't do it,
is it the right thing to allow
states or cities or
whatever to do it?
>> I mean, this opens
a very big question about
technology and regulation.
So, in this country,
we have basically said,
the marketplace will decide
which technology are adopted,
which technology are develop
where the government
just steps aside.
There are some cases now,
I think that we need to really
seriously question that.
I will say the area
where I see it
is clearly in terms
of cyber security.
When the automobile
was introduced,
people started bringing
all kinds of measures.
There was the National
Technology Safety Board,
it's from the 1920s people says,
"Well, within technology,
people are dying,
let's do something about it."
With cyber security, it's
just that people are saying,
"Well, it's like
force of nature.
Nothing we can do."
To me, we are waiting I think,
what's going to happen is
going to be some disaster,
some real disaster, and then,
people say, "Oh, we
need to do something."
Until then, I don't
see anything happening.
You can look at
other things like
cryptocurrencies
because it makes sense.
What are the risks
of cryptocurrencies?
Again, we just unleash
technology and we let it happen,
and let's go see what happens.
I think we're going to see
a lukewarm situation
now that you have
a small number of
companies with the,
I think the big tech
companies that will have
market equity of
close to $3 trillion.
They're employing relatively
small number of people.
Not naming names, some of them
are paying very little taxes.
You kind of put
everything and you can
imagine that Washington would
start looking somewhat
askance and taken,
and maybe, I mean he said
the same thing I have to say,
regulating tech as we've
so it's not in their DNA.
But I cannot, it's quite
conceivable to me that somebody
will stop putting various kinds
of legislations
about technology,
I don't think there
will slow down
the necessarily
the flow of energy,
the development of technology,
but there was amazing piece
of news just this week.
Apple investors want
the company to do something
about the addiction problem
among children and
teenagers in iPhones.
But this did not come
from the association
of distress parents.
These are Apple investors.
Wow. This is
an aha moment, right?
These are investors
that's starting to worry,
this is bad for business.
Mark Zuckerburg just announced,
he's going to change Facebook.
It's going to be a force
for the good, whatever.
I think we're really at
some point that there is some,
that tech has become such a
powerful presence in our life,
and completely unregulated that
people are starting
to look at it.
I don't know what will happen.
I think this is the year where
we're going to see
some change from
the complete less than
fair that we've had for
the past 50 years. Yuri.
>> Comments, you said,
spoke about people
and technology.
We also change. We will
be kind of cyborgs.
So, this is a small remark.
What secondary market,
I think technology,
you cannot stop the film.
Technology, we can
stop in this country,
other countries
will boost up for
being American Medical
Professional work on.
>> Stem cells.
>> Other countries will.
>> Other countries picked
up. So, unfortunately,
I think we come to politics
whether we want it or not,
and one while the population
is more or less,
reason I put
the political system
is completely unreasonable.
All your examples, most of
your examples were from MIT.
If I would give such a talk,
my examples would
come from Chicago.
>> Chicago doesn't
generate jobs.
>> Right, very different
school in economics.
But I think the economic,
the politics in
this country such
that without changing
the basic structure,
there's not much we can do.
Do we want or not?
Somehow have to change
the political life so that
it becomes more reasonable.
So, the reasonable decisions
maybe not only taken,
but even discuss this
without going into
the left right extreme.
>> So, I don't
disagree with you.
We have right now a semi
dysfunctional political system.
I don't have a, many people
are worried about it.
Regardless of this issue,
many people are
worried about it.
I don't have a special wisdom
of how we fix it.
Whether we're becoming cyborgs,
in some sense, we are.
I mean somebody is having
a device on their head,
and there are
some people who may have
device next to their heart.
At some point, maybe
this will happen to
the extent that it will
completely change human nature.
Conceivable to me,
it's too far out,
and I don't have
any special lens
into the future to tell you.
Let's focus on what's
happening in the next 50 years.
After that, it's kind
of science fiction.
Yes, final question maybe.
>> So, I think
the way you describe
basic income as the kind of
social welfare and
charity policy.
>> No, I said it's
actually anti-welfare.
It's an anti-welfare policy.
>> That's what you
think about it, right?
>> Yeah, that's how will
the people in
the component describe it.
>> Okay. But I look
at it as a way,
as a more economic,
more fair economic
policy because
the technology
produces inequality
because of the way we
do technology transfer.
>> Right.
>> If you look at product
like iPhone or laptops,
most of the
intellectual property,
behind it came out of
research paid by the public.
So, the public has been
investing all this time into it,
and yet it's
the companies who first
made the final product
who get all the profit.
So, I think the basic income
would be a way to
create a more fair economic
policy as opposed to charity.
>> So, I actually agree
with everything you say.
I think I said
that the goal of a,
we broke with a proponent to
eliminate welfare program,
and the idea is that
this is the way to share
the wealth in equitable way.
I said I have
one concern about it,
and I said it has proponents
on the left and the right,
and opponent on
the left and the right,
one concern I have is about
the psychological issue.
We used to have another slogan,
which was many people.
My parents thought that this was
used to be a very
beautiful slogan.
Okay? The slogan was,
it's another ulema recognize it.
Form each according
to his needs,
his ability to each
according to her needs.
Okay? And people thought,
wow, what a beautiful slogan.
What a beautiful idea.
People were
really captivated by this.
People who are
willing, people saw
this is such a powerful idea.
People are willing
to kill for it.
And the experiment took
almost 100 years
before we realize,
oh my god, what a
disastrous idea.
Okay? One thing, I
grew up in Israel,
I grew up in Kibbutz.
So, what you may
not know is that,
in addition to the experimental
socialism at large,
there was experimental
socialism in the
small in Israel
in the kibbutzim,
and in kind of
collective settlements.
And it had failed in
the small as well.
So, this beautiful idea,
intellectual fell
in love with it,
and human nature proved to be
somewhat resilient
against this idea.
So, then forward,
everybody come up with
another grand such
idea said, Wow,
let's slow down before we do
any grand experiment
and think about
the consequence and do
it very, very carefully.
Let Finland run experiment
fails. Thank you very much.